vous aujourd'hui est ce que vous pensez
que vous avez une chance d'être en
finale alors d'abord moi j'ai toujours
été une surprise toute ma vie j'ai été
la surprise j'ai été la femme qu'on
n'attendait pas
ma première élection c'était contre un
général qui s'appelle philippe ohayon il
était le favori dans les sondages et on
disait et moi j'étais la gamine est il
allé tollé la gamine ensuite il ya eu
claude bartolone je précise les
régionales en île de france je
souhaitais plier le match plus tôt liée
c'était plié et donc voilà et c'était
pas s'y plier que ça finalement oui en
city la primaire de la droite alors la
primeur de la droite cyril hanouna je
sais pas si quelqu'un a eu m'avait unir
mais ils n'étaient pas nombreux et puis
maintenant il ya cette présidentielle
justement cette primaire de la droite
valérie pécresse vous savez gagner la
primaire et moi ce que je me suis dit je
me suis ni série qu'elle a déjà gagné un
prix bien est ce qu'ils appellent une
décompression des dix j'ai gagné la
primaire et après forcément c'est comme
les qualifications à dans un grand
tournoi et derrière il fallait faire la
campagne est ce que vous n'a pas eu une
petite décompression après ses deux
victoires même vous vous dites que vous
étiez une surprise alors j'ai pas eue
c'était pas tout de suite après juste
après j'ai fait l'union c'était très
important de xavier bertrand à eric
ciotti michel barnier philippe juvin
rassembler la famille et c'était très
important parce que on est de toutes les
sensibilités de la droite il fallait
qu'on souhaite tous ensemble donc juste
après il n'y a pas eu une décompression
mais c'est vrai qu'en fait j'ai eu un
petit coup de fatigue en janvier je le
reconnais je le reconnais bien
volontiers c'est parce que moi j'ai fait
les régionales la primaire de la droite
exactement et j'enchaîne sur la
présidentielle mais pourquoi j j'y vais
pourquoi j'y vais pour quoi j'ai cette
énergie pourquoi je suis remonté sur mon
cheval pourquoi aujourd'hui je me barre
parce que je pense que le projet que je
porte pour le pays c'est le bon parce
que je pense qu'il faut remettre de
l'ordre parce que je pense que la montée
de la violence ça suffit d'ailleurs j'ai
vu que la gale tonnes il s'est fait sur
votre plateau alors que vous avez dit
que vous les êtes là pour verrouiller
une fois aux six mois si oui si j'étais
darmanin là à la sortie du studio il y
aurait eu un policier pour venir leur
demander des comptes là sur le dream
ball et la préfecture un déjà qui
sortait de prison - juste la meilleure
ceux qui ont tiré sur la prévalence et
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle sur les
dalton enfin j'espère qu'ils vont
vraiment qu'ils vont tenir leurs
promesses immo juré qu'il ne ferait plus
aucune mes actions voilà ils l'ont dit
tout à l'heure et m'ont dit on n'en fera
plus à devriez devenir curé vous écoutez
bail déjà
bougé
après chaque match et
non mais vous verrez bon alors on en
reparlera quand vous serez président
peut-être ouvrir et moi je crois je
crois un je crois à la réinsertion de la
deuxième chance je crois à la deuxième
chance mais je crois aussi que quand on
casse on répare voyez alors j'espère
qu'ils vont quand on attaque une
préfecture de seissan leur année fut ni
va bien dit et on espère qu'ils vont qui
vont réparer ça qu'ils vont faire des
bonnes actions parce qu'ils en avaient
fait certaines qui était qui avait été
bien vu d'ailleurs à lyon pour revenir
avoue valérie bègue clasher envie qu'on
vous connaissent un petit peu mieux ce
soir vous êtes bon alors tous les
candidats fabien roussel qui est là
aussi ce soir de yannick jadot la
semaine dernière et il ya aussi quatre
monstres de notoriété en face de jean
luc mélenchon
emmanuel macron eric zemmour qui était
plus connu comme journaliste
éditorialiste marine le pen
vous êtes dans cette bataille et c'est
vrai qu'on vous connaît pas comme on les
connaît e aujourd'hui vous avez une
notoriété qui montre de ses quatre
monstres et vous aller chercher cette
deuxième place donc aujourd'hui j'ai
envie qu'on vous connaissent un peu
mieux j'ai envie aujourd'hui moi de voir
la valérie pécresse que j'ai vu au bord
du ring voilà qui était sympathique qui
parlait à tout le monde je suis rentré
chez moi je dis je connaissais pas
valérie pécresse elle est vraiment
sympathique et tous les gens me disaient
tu as eue il ya valérie pécresse ont
l'air comme elle est sympa ici vrai
qu'on a envie que ce soir vous vous
tombiez le masque on a envie de voir une
valérie pécresse la phr et valérie
pécresse est-ce que vous avez été vous
même dans les différentes émissions vous
avez fait et lors du premier meeting que
vous avez fait est ce que vous êtes
senti à l'aise que vous êtes dit c'est
vraiment ma place est ce que c'est
vraiment moi
non je pense que au zénith j'ai pas
trouvé mon ton c'est ça j'ai voulu faire
un meeting comme un homme est en fait
moi je suis pas un homme et donc après
lenny j'étais déçu évidemment j'ai
trouvé que les critiques étaient pt 1
juste me l'avait aussi plein de défauts
dans les premières ben oui c'était mon
premier très très grande oui et et dans
ces cas là vous savez moi je pense que
dans la vie il ya deux attitudes quand
on trébuche on peut rester à terre où on
peut se relever je pense que quand on
veut présider la france mais il faut
avoir une capacité de se relever il faut
avoir la capacité de remonter sur le
cheval tout de suite alors qu'est ce que
j'ai fait ben quatre jours après au
cannet il y avait 3000 personnes et j'ai
dit non on va tout changer j'ai pris mon
micro et j'ai dit je le faire a cappella
dont 3000 personnes sans discours sans
note et les teams étaient là ici j'étais
en train de se dire c'est la deuxième
lame murat loi du rasoir gillette là
c'est sa deuxième meeting à 3000
personnes là voilà ella a capella et
sans notes et avec mes mots moi j'ai
tout de suite et tout de suite j'ai eu
le sentiment d'être monté sur le cheval
c'est ça et d'avoir été vous même j'ai
été moi même et surtout j'ai trouvé mon
style parce qu'en fait le problème de
ces présidentielles s'il faut trouver il
fautr faux faux fendre l'armure et
l'armure mon armure à moi elle est
épaisse comme ça l épaisse comme ça
parce que parce que j'ai une famille
parce que parce que j'ai pris plein de
coups dans ma vie politique parce qu'il
a fallu que je les protège ce qui est
voilà donc j'ai mis une armure comme ça
et un nom il faut l'ouvrir et c'est vrai
que ceux qui ont plus d'expérience que
moi qui ont déjà fait des campagnes
présidentielles ils savent qu'il faut
fond de l'armure moi j'ai eu un petit
peu de mal j'ai mis du temps et
maintenant on a plus que trois semaines
et donc c'est le moment c'est pour ça
que je suis parti